it's 26 years since first Contact came
out
what does that make me
welcome to Sidetrack your Sci-Fi TV and
movie channel
[Music]
okay so when I watch Star Trek first
Contact I gotta say for me other than
Undiscovered Country which is my
favorite Star Trek Star Trek first
Contact is probably the best all-round
Star Trek movie that's been made it's
definitely the best with Picard and that
lot it's a brilliant proper action movie
in lots of ways but also we got to see
the best villain from Stargate the Borg
now I've got a couple of little fun
facts about the movie on its 26th
anniversary before I tell you what I
really think about this brilliant movie
[Music]
[Music]
first of all Ronald D Moore who wrote it
with Brandon Braga actually wanted to do
a movie with the Borg but the producer
Rick Berman wanted to do a time travel
movie so like all great relationships
they brought their ideas together and
they created Star Trek first Contact but
initially they didn't want to go back to
see zefron Cocker and after World War
III and to see the launch of the Phoenix
no they wanted to go to the Renaissance
period
or with a bloody thinking but luckily
they realized that was the stupidest
idea on the planet now if this had been
a odd numbered Star Trek movie you know
all about the curse I'm sure then they
probably would have gone back to the
Renaissance period and this would have
been a very different movie Jonathan
Frakes actually directed this film now
Jonathan Franks is a director I I kind
of get a little bit angry about this
movie is kind of the only one he's ever
done that I don't hate
Jonathan Franks also directed the
Thunderbirds movie how much of an idiot
do you have to be to ruin a Thunderbirds
movie but if ever you watch it oh he did
oh he ruined it beautifully but he did
not ruin first Contact but he was not
actually the first choice director he
was third they actually approached two
other better known directors who turned
it down and they went with Jonathan
Frakes really because they wanted
somebody that understood what Star Trek
was and somebody that would love the
project as much as everyone else did
because say whatever you like about
Jonathan Franks he is a Star Trek fan
and I actually think he's matured as a
director now his work on strange new
worlds has been fantastic and let's hope
his work on Star Trek Picard Series 3 is
just as good the bork were redesigned
for this movie now before when we'd seen
the book The implants were supposed to
be something that was just attached but
at some point around this time they
decided to bring in the nanotechnology
element to it the Borg actually
assimilates you from the inside out
there was a complete redesign of what
the Borg looked like it took four times
longer to do the makeup but they were
designed to look like it is actually
coming from within you we saw that
famous scene at the start of Star Trek
and first Contact where the comes out of
his cheek and opens up we saw this
technology in a lot more detail in
Voyager later on
this movie though also had one of the
most dramatic scenes in probably any of
the Star Trek movies the Captain Ahab
scene
they're simulated world
and we fall back
not again
the line must be drawn here
there's far no further now we all know
that Patrick Stewart is a damn fine
actor but he really showed just how damn
fine in that scene oh our Captain Picard
also did in that movie it showed how
easy it is for the Holodeck to become a
really dangerous weapon all you have to
do is utter a couple of words computer
disable Holodeck safety protocols and
then machine gun I mean do you Jesus
Christ how is that you could say that by
accident really technology is dangerous
as a Holodeck should probably have some
slightly more security measures I mean
throw in a password or you know like a
retinal scanner fingerprint anything my
phone has got more security measures
than a hollow deck but I'm going to tell
you about when I actually went to see
Star Trek first Contact so this was a
pretty big deal when it was released
people were really excited about it it
was really pre-internet there wasn't you
know YouTube channels and stuff talk
about the movie before it came out so
when we went to see it we did not know
what the Enterprise looked like and I
actually went to a trackathon so they
showed all of the Trek movies back to
back and then they showed Star Trek
first Contact about five o'clock in the
morning really before anybody else had
seen it but on the day of its release
I have to admit about three o'clock in
the morning during
um the final frontier I fell asleep I
did snore through God sorry when we got
to see first Contact and we got to
seeing the first sweeping shot of the
new Enterprise E
H there was an actual audible gasp now
you've got to remember I'm British I was
in a British Cinema an audible like that
was like that was just losing their
freaking Minds now we were trekkies we
were very invested in this movie we've
had lots of fun during the night doing
little quizzes between the movies and
things but we're still British we still
don't really show our emotion
particularly not in public that audible
gasp really said everything this was an
incredibly beautiful ship and it's an
incredibly beautiful shot and the
Enterprise E it's probably my favorite
of the bunch
now Star Trek first Contact for me is
probably the most rounded of all the
Star Trek movies it doesn't really have
any weak moments in it even though I
never really understood why laforge and
Riker went aboard the Phoenix with
Cochrane
don't know why they did that other than
the fact that obviously in the movie
they wanted them aboard but I could use
different [ __ ] and they say well we're
coming and they're like why I Can Fly
the thing on my own why have we even put
three seats in the damn thing I I never
really got that but other than that it
was just a beautifully made movie this
bore Queen first time we saw that
brilliant the whole thing with data I
was tempted by her offer
a longer time
0.68 seconds Sir
it's the most rounded move out of all
the Star Treks there isn't any weak
points in the movie I'm really thinking
the only film that comes close to it is
probably the Wrath of Khan because even
though Undiscovered Country is my
favorite movie and it's got some amazing
bits in it it's my favorite movie
because it was the first Star Trek's
film I ever got to see at the cinema
it's probably got the best opening
sequence put a whole bit in the Middle
with the prison and Praxis is is a bit
weak and obviously Nemesis and 100
Insurrection have real massive
weaknesses in them
first Contact just doesn't there are no
bits this movie that you can say I'll
just skip past that I'll wander off and
make a cup of tea now the whole film is
fast paced action pace and really a
well-rounded story
but guys get in the comments tell me
what you think what do you think a Star
Trek first Contact and can you believe
it's 26 years old 26.
I'm not even doing the math on how old
that makes me if you are new to the
Channel please like subscribe hit that
Bell notification it really helps us out
and if you enjoy the content please
consider hitting that join button and
becoming a fully fledged side tracker
because that really supports the channel
as always please stay safe and I'll see
you next time
[Music]